a man has pleaded guilty to murdering 35
year old Zara Alina in ilfords in East
London in June of this year let's see if
we can get some more information on this
uh Ashner hurinag joins us now from the
old bayley uh Ashner what more can you
tell us about this
well Zara Elena has been had been
walking home on the 26th of June in the
early hours after spending an evening
out with friends and as she walked home
just 10 minutes from her front door she
was attacked by Jordan McSweeney who
today at the Old Bailey has pleaded
guilty to her murder and guilty of
sexual assault CCTV footage appears to
show McSweeney searching around for a
Target on that night he can see him
fixating on a number of women we heard
the prosecution describe on an earlier
hearing before he ultimately targets
Zara he then leads her onto a driveway
and it's understood that he then
proceeds to kick and stamp her and
attempts to rape her as well hence the
charge of sexual assault in this case
the 35 year old Zara Alina was found
with serious head injuries and she was
taken by paramedics shortly after the
assault to a nearby hospital where she
later died we spoke to Zara as family
members when at the time of her murder
only a few months ago they described her
as being an incredibly Fierce woman
someone who was incredibly caring and
warm-hearted and that she was somebody
that said that women should be allowed
to walk by themselves home and safely
and ultimately it was Jordan McSweeney
we have found out today who took Zara of
her life it's understood that Jordan
McSweeney had only been released from
prison on license a few days before this
killing happened it's understood he was
serving time for burglary offenses and
ultimately here today at the Old Bailey
he has admitted the murder of zaralina
okay bring us up to date from the Old
Bailey Ashner thank you